as the drone racing league prepares for
a big debut in 2016 it wants to make
sure its drones are ready for the
spotlight to keep races fair the DRL
team builds all its racing drones to the
same specifications and to keep things
interesting those specifications will
change from race to race in DRL events
we use our own in-house design and
custom-built drones it helps level the
playing field for the pilots and gives
us a lot of control over the technology
that's involved in it the process of
designing and executing these drones is
always a constant balance between flight
time and the amount of LEDs and how
visible it is they're capable of about
80 miles an hour they stay in the air
for about six minutes they hold a GoPro
front config because we do a lot of
filming the technology that's used in
drone racing today is drawn from a
variety of sources the controllers are
drawn mainly from the world of model
aviation and remote-control cars the
goggles are drawn from the early days of
on-screen displays our internal
components are designed to be a
streamlined as possible we have as few
points of failure in the drone as we can
you have your battery which is your
power source
you've got your flight controller which
is kind of the brains of the whole
operation
you've got electronic speed controllers
the battery is a lithium polymer which
gives us a really nice balance of power
and weight that are made with a 5-inch
prop 22:06 motors the transmitters are a
little more intimidating looking than a
playstation controller but they do
disagree the same thing the left stick
is throttle in y'all and the right stick
is rolling pitch what that allows you to
do is finally control the angle of the
tremor and really do aerobatic things we
got rid of all the stuff you don't need
to race and it's just as bare-bones as
possible drone racing league CEO Nick
Corbett Chesky likens his league to
Formula One or NASCAR professional
drivers like Lewis Hamilton don't need
to worry about tuning up their own
engine or replacing their tires they're
just there to compete the process of the
pilots going in and adjusting all the
individual settings is something we call
tuning it's a lot like tuning a car it's
going through and finding everything you
can bury to make it drive just the way
you want you can tune literally every
setting of the drone in the flight
controller software so you can control
how fast it spins how fast it rolls you
can limit your throttle if you wanted to
you can make it completely custom to you
drones are made to withstand crashing we
build them with fifth carbon fiber we
use aluminum fasteners and we try and
make it as lightweight but as durable as
possible the name of the game is to
design it to crash well and repair it
easily so we'll go through a lot of
drugs
there's crashes in every race it's
exciting it's fun the pilots know it and
it's how they know they're pushing the
boundaries of flying the pilots are more
likely to take risks in a race if they
don't have to worry about repairing
their own vehicles and that makes the
race videos a lot more exciting